- Conetoe was a food desert.
But I wanted to do somethin' about it.
We began to grow, and we began
to put our hearts and hands together,
and Conetoe is no longer a food desert.
Conetoe is a food oasis.
(piano music)
I'm Reverend Richard R. Joyner,
founder of Conetoe Family Life Center.
Conetoe is a rural area
in the eastern part of North Carolina.
Population of about 300 people.
A food desert really means
that the residents here
do not have access to fresh,
locally affordable grown foods.
We would buy most of our
food from discount stores,
which are high in sodium, calories,
very low in nutritional values.
People had these early
stages of chronic disease,
diabetes, high blood pressure,
heart attacks, strokes,
and even mental illness because
of the stress and the pain.
People were dyin' in their 30s and 40s.
We would be havin' two
to three funerals a month
and really devastating families.
(engine rumbling)
I was really feelin' overwhelmed,
and feelin' hopeless,
because I couldn't stop
this chronic disease.
I pulled on the side of the road
and really started praying,
wanting to know what could I do.
And I had this epiphany of
open your eyes, look around.
And I'd open my eyes,
and all I saw was fields.
(piano music)
So, we started our first small garden.
And now we're up to 21 acres of farmland.
We have about eight people
that are parents and
grandparents of our youth,
that work here every day.
We have 40 students durin'
the summer that use this farm
for their readin',
writin', math and science
and for food.
Presently on our farm, we
have blueberries, tomatoes;
we have collards; we have
squash; we have zucchini.
We end up averaging 100
pounds of food per week
out of the garden.
Food that we grow has
had a tangible impact
upon our community.
We're able to put food on people's tables.
Hello, I have your vegetables.
- Hello, Reverend Joyner.
- [Richard] All right, our
community is spending $4,000
less a month on prescription
pills, because the food--
- The deaths have slowed down;
we're not havin' as many funerals.
I feel like we are makin' a difference.
I love this community
here because we're unitin'
around savin' lives together.
(acoustic guitar music)
(electronic music)